Life is a mess. There are all kinds of forms
of life on this planet, and any time you want
to do anything scientific it’s good to have
some kind of organizing principle. Biologists
use a very rough organizing principle for
defining types of life by calling them ‘species.’
‘Species’ traditionally was the distinction
of different animals or different forms of
life which cannot interbreed or, even if they
do interbreed, their offspring cannot reproduce.
This is a rough definition of course, but
it was useful in categorizing and enumerating
the number of types of of forms of life on
Earth there are. And now that that list is
in the millions, we have a very complicated
web of what the tree of life looks like. But
even more interesting is that the ability
to access the genetic information of different
species had allowed biologists to see where
the lines are blurred between two different
types or more species. What they found was
interesting. First, that species — there
are many species which interbreed. They have
sex with each other, and they produce offspring
and a lot of genetic information is shared
between species. But what they’ve also found
is that there are genetic distinguishing features
that remain robust. It’s like if you have
two cans of paint and you pour them into each
other — say one yellow and one red — and
you mix it all up and it all turns orange
except for these spots. Some are exactly red
and the other ones are yellow and they don’t
blend for some reason — parts of the DNA
which stay robustly distinct between two species.
One example is in northern Europe there are
two different species of crows, the carrion
and the hooded crow. And yet they do interbreed,
and they do live geographically in overlapping
places. And yet, their distinguishing features
remain. In fact, their genetic codes are so
similar that you, looking at the DNA, would
never call them different species, and yet
they look completely different and therefore
are easily distinguished. And the question
is: ‘Why?’ Why is it so robust? And we
don’t know. And so studying the genomes
in great detail, of neighboring species and
lots of different species, we can understand
what we mean by the word ‘species’ at all.